otro paso más para revivir el acuerdo
nuclear con irán
de verification and monitoring
activities that we grid el equipo de
verificación y monitoreo de las
actividades que acordamos continuarán
como hasta ahora por un mes más for one
man's expirando entonces el 24 de junio
de 2021
ranking 34 el jefe del organismo de
control nuclear de naciones unidas se
refirió a la ampliación del plazo de
tres meses que se enmarca en un acuerdo
confidencial llamado protocolo adicional
éste culminó el viernes su prolongación
a un mes permite a teherán washington y
otras potencias mundiales que dispongan
de más tiempo para negociar y no sabemos
qué sanciones habría que levantar si son
compatibles con el acuerdo nuclear pero
igual de importante y de hecho más
importante es que irán sabe lo que tiene
que hacer para volver a cumplir con el
acuerdo nuclear y lo que aún no hemos
visto es irán está preparado y dispuesto
a tomar la decisión de hacer lo que
tiene que hacer esa es la prueba y aún
no tenemos una respuesta y esa respuesta
llegó en forma de tweet del principal
diplomático iraní javad sharif dijo el
lunes que eliminar esas medidas
punitivas es una obligación legal y
moral las idas y venidas se producen
horas después de que un miembro del
destacado equipo de negociador de irán
informará al comité de seguridad
nacional y política exterior del
parlamento del país diciendo que las
sanciones estaban negociando en dos
partes las primeras en ser eliminadas
incluirían las dirigidas a la industria
petrolera y al sector bancario de
teherán ahora -según el presidente-
hassan rohan y las próximas semanas
serán probablemente la etapa más
decisiva de las conversaciones en curso
la gran pregunta ahora es se salvará el
pacto antes de que los iraníes acudan a
las urnas el 18 de junio